so the Xbox one was unveiled last week a
lot of controversy because of it so I
suppose we should talk about that [ __ ]
first and foremost because I want to
talk about that [ __ ] and to lay the
groundwork here it's no secret to my
subscribers I am a PlayStation gamer I
have a ps3 I have a PC I don't have an
Xbox 360 i used to have an xbox 360 and
it was like hey guess what red ring then
I didn't have one anymore that might be
fair here because I don't want to see
Microsoft fail in their new console I
like to think that even though this Xbox
one has problems and obviously the
people who made it have a skewed
perspective as to what is good for the
gamer it's not too late to turn back so
I'm gonna address what's wrong with the
picture also because I like a
competitive market if Xbox fails Sony
will own the market yeah there will be
Nintendo with their Wii U also but I
never really saw the Wii U as a next-gen
console if you look at it
technologically speaking it's like a
current gen console but it just came out
in time for next gen systems it's like
the Wii it's its own thing if you really
want to look at the competition
it is Xbox and Playstation and if Xbox
goes away and we don't have that
competitive gaming market and Sony's
going to own the market if Sony owns the
market human nature says they're gonna
get lazier they're not going to try new
things go to the next step you know to
push their tech to the next level
they'll be like we own a tall people
play our stuff because they have nowhere
else to go whatever let's get lazy I
don't want to see that happen either I
like a competitive gaming market so with
that if the people of Microsoft are
watching here is what we the people
don't like about the Xbox one the main
thing that made people back up with the
Xbox want to be like whoa I I don't
think I like that it's the little thing
where you buy the disc and then you put
the disc in the system and it uploads it
onto your hard drive and now that game
from that disc is playable only on your
system which means you can't loan the
game to your friend which is a big part
of gaming which is funny because that's
not solving anything people have loaned
their games to their friends for years
ever since the invention of pong from
before the time of the NES to now people
loan their games to their friends like
oh yeah I have this game you want to
borrow it oh yeah here you go here's
milan secret Castle don't move away so I
don't see you anymore and I lose my
Milan secret castle oh you did that
actually happened that was [ __ ]
although that game was [ __ ] but it
was still [ __ ] point is I don't know
how this is gonna solve anything you're
just taking away from an aspect of
gaming if this is the way it's going at
least implement some sort of digital
eReader new cloning system or something
if you don't know what that is the nook
and other digital readers I believe the
Amazon Kindle does this also or if you
have your digital eReader and someone
else has the same digital eReader you
can electronically
loan them your book for like two weeks
you don't have it anymore they do and
then they finish it then it's back on
your nook and off of theirs do something
like that so you can loan your games
back and forth between your friends
digitally of course but still or at
least if you're going to a friend's
house you can play the game that you
want to play with him without hauling
your entire system to his place the
whole reason they're doing this it's all
locking one game into one system thing
is to eliminate used game sales and
retail stores yeah the time was use game
sales didn't exist at all from the game
entering the retail store to the time
that the retail store stopped selling
the game life was good for game creators
and retail stores started taking in
trade ins and then they started
reselling the games as used games saying
is those retail stores keep 100% of the
profit of those game sales so now game
companies make the brunt of their
profits when the game comes out and
people start trading it in then retail
stores start selling the used copies
people buy the used copies and then the
game makers don't make that much profit
off of it anymore
thus the gaming market is trying to
eliminate that and now gamers are kind
of getting screwed I understand the
escalation aspect where the retail
stores were like hey we found a system
that works for us it makes us money then
the game makers are like well this is
going to eliminate that so we make more
money game creators want the most
revenue possible for their game but in
trying to get your piece of the pie you
can't screw over the consumer it will
just lead to more problems however
Microsoft address this and they said
that retailers will have a have a thing
a device of some sort when someone
trades in the game to a retailer that
retailer puts the disc in this device
that device reads the disc and through
the internet it'll wipe out the content
from the gaming console that that disc
was burned to and so all's right with
the world it's like it never happened
however new cogs in the system means new
costs new cost means higher prices which
means the whole point of used games
really is not there at all this whole
system looks like it's Microsoft given
the illusion that they're trying to work
with people but in the end it's going to
lead to the elimination of use game
sales anyway so it's really the same
effect as them being like can't deal
with it what do I mean by that I mean
this let's say a new game is 60 bucks
the use game will probably be 50 to 55
however there is going to be a fee that
someone has to pay to play this used
game that's been wiped from someone
else's console and now is replayable
again I know Microsoft's been like oh
it's the retailer that's going to pay
for it not the people however it's no
better because if the retailer has to
pay money for it that means they're
going to jack up the price of the used
game or they're going to give you less
money for trading in the game anyway
point is people are still getting
screwed and now we hear rumors that this
fee that retailers have to pay for
taking in a used game might be upwards
50 bucks that might be a little inflated
because that's just absurd that will
clearly eliminate used games point is
retailers are going to have to jack up
the price of used games so people are
gonna buy new games anyway which means
retailers are gonna stop carrying used
games which means the used game market
is going to go away anyway however I
look at it it just seems to lead to the
same Road and what about people who want
to sell their games at a garage sale or
something they're not gonna have that
little piece of tech that wipes it out
from someone else's Xbox a little Timmy
can't sell his games and he doesn't want
anymore at a garage sale so we can make
more doing that than trading it into a
company it's going to give him 1/10 of
what he could make at his garage sale
I'm sure a lot of you just thought well
that's the same system that PC games do
right now PC games you look at him you
get him you have a code it locks to your
own account on Steam or whatever it's
true and it's the same thing and that is
why I'm pretty sure that used games are
going to go away for the Xbox one used
game sales for modern PC games ya know
in my experience and this is a general
statement but this is just my experience
Xbox gamers are not PC gamers if you try
to change out a console gaming
experience and replace it with a PC
gaming experience overnight your fans
are gonna get a little cantankerous
people are very sensitive we need to be
climatized into something we're like
goldfish I don't know if you know this
about goldfish when you're changing the
water in a goldfish bowl you need to put
the goldfish in a baggie with the water
he's used to then change out the water
in the goldfish bowl then put the baggie
containing the old water and the
goldfish into the goldfish bowl and then
leave them there totally that's
climatized to it he's used to the
temperature then you can release the
goldfish into the water just throw the
goldfish into the bowl with fresh new
water he's just gonna go to shock and
die it metaphorically do the same thing
to a gaming system that people are used
to same thing will happen in step by
going to shock and die I mean go
somewhere else somewhere they might be
able to hold on to the gaming experience
that they've grown on for the past
decade I guess if I can sum up the Xbox
one's gripes it's control everything
seems very big brother is watching you
we're controlling the way you're gaming
the freedom of gaming's being taken away
from players and replaced with a
structure in which Microsoft's like note
you need to game like this because we
say so Oh it'll come with a Kinect the
Kinect is always going to be on does
that creep anyone else out that creeps
me out I don't even know why it creeps
me out I just I feel like if something
if there's a camera on something or
someone's watching me it's just an
uncomfortable feeling to know even if
it's not happening it's just
uncomfortable ever get that feeling like
I feel like I'm being watched even if
you're not it's never a pause
if no one's ever like oh I think I'm
being watched that's awesome now so the
little Xbox I that's looking at you
everyone's gonna be like someone looking
at me right now so eliminate that [ __ ]
I think Sony played a smart even if they
did plan on going the route that Xbox
one is going they didn't let us know
that so now all the fallout that
Microsoft's getting you know so many
people are screaming and phones there
are D Department they're like you have
four months to find out how to not do it
the way we were going to do it again
it's not too late Microsoft can come out
and be like ok we screwed up we're
making it right we've listened to you
guys I think it's a mark of integrity if
a game companies like a we're listening
to the fans and you didn't like what we
had cool we're fixing it gonna cost him
quite a few bucks and Rd setbacks yes
but is that really worse than like 2% of
the people out there being interested in
your product which is pretty much the
situation now I don't have the graphs it
could be more than 2% but I'm just
saying I haven't heard one single person
that I personally know go yeah I'm done
with Xbox one those are all great ideas
we all have things to say about it
because none of us like it all for very
similar reasons
if this perception is clearly wrong then
I think Microsoft should throw another
press conference like today and clarify
the situation because this perception is
what I see this is what my friends see
everyone I know we're all like yeah
we're on the same page this is what it
looks like and this is not good this is
terrible I could be wrong about assuming
that Sony's not going to do something
like this though
just because they've been tight-lipped
doesn't mean they're not going to do
exactly what Microsoft is doing simply
because I don't think that Microsoft
would jump on doing something so extreme
if the competition wasn't doing it also
couldn't you just see like a confab a
power of the minds of Microsoft and Sony
and they're like okay we're both going
to do this right I mean no backing down
now we're both on board we're gonna do
this we gotta go all the way here no
backing out and screwin the other one
over but you never know I really hope
Sony doesn't do what Microsoft is doing
and I hope Microsoft rein IG's on this
whole concept because if both powers end
up doing it I think the next-gen
experience is just gonna suck ass all
Sony has to do is come out and go oh ps4
is not going to be like that you will
still be able to game the way you're
used to gaming come on over folks
and then they'll win that's what
happened they will win all right so the
Xbox one and the points made here what
do you think about this whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you